a widespread misconception among lay
audiences is that mathematical physics
has rational explanations for how our
universe works
many research popular mantras that your
computer wouldn't work if quantum
mechanics were wrong
and others will tell you that general
relativity is correct because otherwise
we wouldn't have developed gps
but when you ask the mathematicians
not one
can explain to you the physical
mechanism that underlies gravity
not one can tell you how one magnet
physically attracts another one
[Music]
nobel prize richard feynman is on record
stating that i can safely say that
nobody understands quantum mechanics
do not keep asking yourself if you can
possibly avoid it but how can it be like
that
nobody knows how it can be like that the
more you see how strangely nature
behaves the harder it is to make a model
that explains how even the simplest
phenomena actually work
so theoretical physics has given up on
that
another prominent mathematical physicist
wrote an article whose title speaks for
itself
even physicists don't understand quantum
mechanics
he wrote that
if nobody understands quantum mechanics
nobody understands the universe
and emeritus professor drives home the
point in case you missed it
science doesn't explain
science describes
all we need to do now is discover the
differences between descriptions and
explanations
let's first cover first base
if it's irrational the explanation is no
explanation at all
a theorist should be able to make a
movie of the mechanism he or she
proposes
the audience should be able to watch
the mechanism on the big screen
what images
would a theorist put in a film for
concepts such as love or energy
and this realization
leads us to our definition
in physics to explain means to reveal
the mechanism that underlies a
phenomenon
articulating what caused an event to
happen
an explanation is the prosecutor's
version of the causes that underlie the
workings of the universe
the theorist paints an objective picture
of the scenes necessary to understand
the mechanism
an explanation deals exclusively with
the past
in contrast a description is either a
robotic listing of properties of an
object
or a typically chronological recitation
of events without identifying the causes
an equation is just a synthesized
description of motion and behavior
an equation has no power or authority to
tell you what physical mechanisms
underlie phenomena such as gravity and
magnetism
mathematics is exclusively a language of
descriptions
[Music]
you